next we move on to the category of
animation bronze medal honors this year
go to a film from a school whose
animation work has been rewarded many
times in the past few years of these
awards made at the ringling college of
art design by Eric pro my little friend
is the story of a hobo and pigeon well I
want to start off by thanking the
Academy for flying me out here for
showing me all this awesome stuff for
giving me this award it's been a lot of
fun I want to thank my composure a jack
bender for writing the score for my film
without to him the film would not have
had music which I think helped a lot I
definitely want to thank my parents for
always supporting me the faculty at
Ringling and the cool people like
moonbot studios for all the advice the
notes the critiques that you gave me
over the past few years all my awesome
friends at Ringling for just being there
for me 24 hours a day for it always
being fun and for making the whole
process a lot more enjoyable it's been
great you guys you're awesome yeah
thanks again thanks everyone